the movie begins by introducing us to
Nancy Stokes a 55 year old woman who
finds herself in a state of unhappiness
after the recent loss of her husband and
her retirement all her life Nancy has
been an honorable woman who has adhered
to the societal expectations placed upon
her however one aspect of her life has
remained unfulfilled her intimate
experiences despite her being 55 years
old she has never had good intercourse
this is what she wants to change at all
costs time to book Nancy a date with
Shrek in the first scene Nancy conducts
an online research and discovers a
handsome escort named Leo Grande she
immediately books his services and rents
an upscale hotel room where no one can
recognize her at this point Nancy is a
bit nervous about the encounter as she
has never dated a guy before let alone
be intimate with a complete stranger
however she hopes that by spending time
with Leo she can finally experience the
pleasure that she has been missing the
following morning Nancy reaches the
hotel room early and tries to settle in
each passing minute increases her
anxiety as the anticipated meeting
approaches but just as she begins to
feel overwhelmed Leo arrives at her
doorstep with a gentle request he asks
for a warm kiss on the cheek instantly
leaving Nancy impressed she can't help
but mention how much more attractive he
is in person compared to his photo as a
gesture of hospitality she offers him a
refreshing drink from the minibar and
the two engage in polite conversation in
the midst of it Leo notices that Nancy
is trembling so he asks if everything is
all right in response she mentions that
she feels embarrassed due to the
significant age difference between them
Nancy has started having second thoughts
about this meeting and she believes that
what she's doing is morally wrong
however Leo being the gentleman that he
is assures her that it is perfectly fine
he also compliments that she is
extremely attractive and has a great
body to make her feel better he even
kisses her passionately as Nancy regains
her confidence she begins talking about
her past she reveals that her late
husband was the only partner she ever
had but their intimate life was terrible
he never allowed her to perform oral
intercourse believing that it was
humiliating what was he insane most of
the time her husband would just kiss her
on the forehead and go to sleep after
this Nancy reveals something shocking
she has never experienced an orgasm in
her lifetime no they're they're a myth
she isn't intending to get one right now
as she feels too nervous Leo understands
her feelings and doesn't try to force
the matter instead he hugs her tightly
hoping to ignite the erotic flame within
her following this Nancy heads to the
bathroom to change into her new
nightgown while Leo grabs a candy bar
and eats it when she eventually comes
out she finds him lying on the bed in a
seductive manner however Nancy is not
enticed at all she instead mentions that
she doesn't like the smell of the
chocolate he just had because of this
poor Leo heads to the bathroom to brush
his teeth upon his return Nancy tells
him that she has changed her mind she no
longer wants to have intercourse as she
doesn't think it is right for her she
tells Leo that he can leave with the
money however he chooses to stay and
talk to her he curiously inquires why a
beautiful woman like her decided to hire
Court when she could have easily
attracted other men in response Nancy
reveals that several men her age have
expressed interest in her but she
rejected them all that's because she
only likes young men flip the genders
here in this movie is a problem Nancy
then opens up more about herself she
reveals that she used to teach religious
education but feels a lack of guidance
and meaning in her own life she also
confesses that she has made sacrifices
for the sake of her two children but
even then they have become distant from
her throughout her life Nancy has put
aside her own dreams and desires playing
the roles of a dutiful daughter wife
mother and teacher she feels as if she
has wasted her life by always trying to
do things correctly Nancy also admits to
being self-conscious about her
appearance influenced by her mother's
teachings about vanity however Leo
reassures her that it's perfectly fine
to be confident and appreciate one's
physical attractiveness as their
conversation deepens a growing fondness
and affection develops between them
Nancy is for sure on track to score that
young dong after some time Nancy becomes
curious and asks Leo if his mother knows
about his profession she wonders if he
has a troubled past or if he ran away
from difficult circumstances Leo shares
that his mother actually believes he
works on an oil rig She is totally
unaware of his real occupation well he
does drill holes he further says that
providing intimate Services is an
important job so if he doesn't feel
guilty or regretful about what he does
hearing this Nancy feels a bit better
realizing that she's not the only one
with these desires she in turn reveals
her most sensual encounter to date it
was 30 years ago when she along with her
family were on a vacation in Greece
Nancy encountered a good-looking waiter
and started making out with him however
their romantic moment was abruptly cut
short with the arrival of a car Nancy
still thinks about that waiter today and
regrets not doing much more with him as
she continues sharing her intimate past
she becomes more at ease Leo senses this
and abruptly kisses her surprisingly
Nancy gets excited by it and finally
gives in to her desires the two then
make out and have a wonderful love
making session a few days later Nancy
contacts Leo again and invites him back
to the same room she didn't invite
anyone else as she was very satisfied by
Leo's previous Service as soon as he
arrives Nancy hands him a list of erotic
experiences that she wants to try for
the first time it includes engaging in
oral intercourse however Leo notices
that Nancy intentionally crossed
experiencing an orgasm off the list when
asked about it she explains that she
wants to take things one step at a time
unfortunately Nancy once again feels
unsure about getting close to Leo things
worsen when her overly dependent
daughter calls adding to her worries
fortunately though Leo is there to help
her relax he gives her a massage and
even dances with her to calm her mind
Leo advises her not to put too much
pressure on herself to fulfill all her
Desires in one night when Nancy talks
about sacrificing her Youth and missed
Adventures for her family Leo finally
talks about his own family he reveals
that he has a younger brother who serves
in the military however they don't talk
much these days after some time Leo
suggests that Nancy Book more sessions
with him so that he can help reduce her
stress unfortunately this offends Nancy
as she believes that he is only here for
the money Leo quickly defends himself by
expressing that he genuinely cares for
her well-being hearing this Nancy can't
help but wonder why someone as
charismatic as him would choose to work
in this field and what kind of difficult
circumstances led him to do it Nancy
holds outdated beliefs about sex workers
which are commonly held misconceptions
however Leo disputes her assumptions by
claiming that he genuinely enjoys his
work he is not ashamed of what he does
because he understands that it can bring
happiness and benefit to others
additionally his profession involves
more than just intercourse at times some
women have asked him for massages some
have booked him for a genuine date
sometimes he even plays the fiddle at
birthday parties and some have even
hired him to prepare food in the kitchen
as he continues explaining his field of
work Nancy gets excited and begins
engaging in oral intercourse with him
this makes her more confident and the
two once again end up having coitus in
the next scene Leo and Nancy have their
third appointment in the same room they
have a wonderful time trying different
positions and techniques with each
passing minute and their relationship
grows stronger and they tick off several
items from Nancy's list of desires even
the fabled Mexican birthday party
however Nancy still does not experience
an orgasm after the romance session is
over Nancy becomes curious and tries to
pry into Leo's personal life seeking
more information however he firmly
refuses explaining that his role is
solely to provide fantasy and nothing
else but despite his clear boundaries
Nancy's curiosity gets the better of her
and she begins delving into Leo's
relationships with his family Nancy
admits to having stalked Leo Online and
discovered his real name Connor she
expresses a desire to be friends outside
of their sessions and advises Leo to
share his work with his family
unfortunately this invasion of privacy
infuriates him as a result he quickly
changes back into his clothes and
angrily tells her not to book him again
he also warns her against contacting his
family or disclosing his personal
information threat to reveal her as a
customer if she does after this Leo
storms out of the room but then returns
to retrieve his phone while looking for
it he angrily opens up to Nancy about
his troubled relationship with his
mother he shares that when he was 15
years old his mother disowned him
because she despised who he was going as
far as telling people that he was dead
when Nancy asks what he did to his mom
Leo becomes even angrier expressing his
frustration at her making assumptions
saying this he leaves the room for good
a few days later Nancy books Leo for a
fourth session as an apology and a
farewell gesture but this time she wants
to meet him in a cafe while waiting she
encounters Becky a former student who
happens to work as a waitress in the
same Cafe as they chat Leo arrives
prompting Nancy to create a story that
they're there for business the waitress
then takes their order and leaves giving
the two some personal space Nancy
immediately takes this opportunity to
apologize to Leo she reveals that her
real name is Susan Robinson and
expresses her gratitude to him for
helping her gain confidence and explore
her sexuality Nancy also mentions that
she has recommended Leo's services to
other women in her social group who she
believes could benefit from his
assistance just like she did hearing all
this Leo becomes happy and promptly
forgives her he then confesses that his
mother disowned him when she caught him
having group coitus with his friends
even when they recently crossed paths in
public his mother refused to acknowledge
Him Leo also mentions that he has
informed his brother about his job and
the latter is cool with it right then
Becky interrupts their conversation and
reveals that Nancy was an awful teacher
in the past she called the students
escorts just because they wore short
clothes hearing this Nancy feels awful
and apologizes for her past actions she
then tells Becky that she is a
completely different person now who has
realized that pleasure is not a bad
thing all of a sudden she also confesses
about her relationship with Leo and even
recommends his services to Becky
that's a little extreme in the next
scene the two head to the hotel room and
make passionate love this time Nancy
finally experiences her first orgasm
after their encounter is over Nancy
tells Leo that this will be their last
session as she has experienced
everything she wanted to however she
wants them to remain France and he
happily agrees the movie ends as Nancy
looks into the mirror and admires her
body for the first time in years she is
finally content and happy
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching